Let's go next to I want to go to I think we're
going to the U.K. now with Ian from South
Hampton.
Ian, welcome to the program.
What's on your mind?
So I have some tactic's questions regarding
Biden's performance last night.
Please.
I watched the whole thing.
It was about three a.m. to 4:00 am for me.
So I was a little bit out of it.
But I did notice that he actually just came
out and said that Trump was the worst presence
of the night.
Yes.
That was a great moment in my mind.
Well, here's the thing for me.
The way he delivered that actually the way
he delivered a number of the other insults,
which I think are really just adjectives.
Yes.
I was in a way that didn't necessarily seem
to be serious.
It didn't seem to be the denunciation that
should be, it seems, very Joe Biden.
This is all you know, it's kind of funny what
this Trump guy is and who he thinks he is.
You know, I don't totally disagree.
And by the way, I'm hearing all sorts of discord
tweets and beep.
So if you can mute those, that that would
be a beautiful thing.
How would I do that?
That I don't know.
But my what I was going to say is I actually
liked the Biden laughing because Trump is
a narcissist and Trump is an authoritarian.
He wants people angry and afraid and nothing
communicates the opposite.
Then Biden just laughing Trump off as an unserious
person.
So I. I don't disagree with you with the micro,
which is when Biden said Trump's the worst
president ever.
He didn't really do it in the serious denunciation
way we might have liked to see.
But it was part of just laughing the guy off.
And I think Trump really didn't like that.
Yeah.
So this is kind of my next point is that.
To me, what that signaled is on some level
that Trump isn't necessarily a threat and
Trump isn't serious.
And he did have that big moment at the end
where he was talking.
You did the very serious look to camera.
Yes, I can vote, which I liked again.
But it's it seems that the sort of laughing,
laughing off at that base, at least laughing
for some of it is fine.
And some of the sillier stuff he said was
fine.
Yeah.
But I feel that he missed the mark with some
of the insults and the denunciations.
All right.
Fair point and point well taken.
Ian, I'm going to let you go because the beeps
are just there.
Yeah, no doubt about it.
They're creating a problem for us, but it's
a point taken and reasonable people can can
certainly disagree.